nous avons jeté les républicains est
derrière ce terme de républicains il y a
un sens qui est la modernisation de
notre république
tout ça doit être portée par un projet
il n'y a pas de parti politique sans
projet reparti et les hommes et des
femmes qui même famille politique
partagent les mêmes convictions
le projet c'est un socle en réalité un
socle de valeurs qu'il faut que nous
déterminions tous ensemble d'ici le
début 2016
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être français
aujourd'hui comment on voit l'avenir de
la france en europe et dans le monde
un projet économique un projet social le
code du travail qu'il faut transformer
l'économie qu'il faut libérer les
entreprises qu'il faut mettre en avant
est lui aussi un projet sociétal
je pense évidemment à l'intégration à
l'immigration à l'ouverture au monde à
l'europe
et je souhaiterais que les uns et les
autres puissent venir construire ce
projet avec nous il doit être
interactives contributif comme on dit
aujourd'hui si j'ai décidé de rejoindre
la grande famille des républicains
c'est parce que j'en suis persuadé
ensemble nous pouvons porter une
écologie modéré et réaliste pragmatique
avec une vision du monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui avec le grenelle de
l'environnement et le grenelle de la mer
nicolas sarkozy a su montrer qu'avec de
la volonté on pouvait rassembler et
faire bouger les choses
l'écologie l'environnement ne peut pas
être réservé à l'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui chez les républicains nous
pouvons porter ce message je me suis
engagé tout naturellement républicain
première force d'opposition afin de
participer à la reconstruction d'un pays
au sein des républicains ma charge et en
effet de mobiliser l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques et plus
spécifiquement les entrepreneurs sur
notre projet pour les mobiliser parce
que le projet ne pourra pas se faire
sans eux et la reconquête de la france
était attendu dans la française ne
pourra pas se faire sans eux les
questions de société
aujourd'hui
sont très importantes dans la
construction du futur projet des
républicains je pense notamment à la
question de la fin de vie qui est un
débat non réglé aujourd'hui mais nous
avons aussi la question de la gestation
pour autrui et il est absolument
essentiel que notre mouvement puisse
débattre ouvrir ces sujets même si ce
sont des sujets difficiles
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un grand projet
de l'alternance c'est un projet qui
réponde aux préoccupations de nos
compatriotes
nous avons un premier fléau c'est le
chômage
mille chômeurs par jour ouvré depuis
2012 nous avons à relever le défi de la
des publics
nous serons un des deux pays d'europe
dans lequel à des publics sera la plus
élevée à la fin de cette année nous
avons le déficit quand nicolas sarkozy a
quitté le pouvoir en 2012 la cour des
comptes a noté que la tendance était la
bonne aujourd'hui cela s'aggrave à la
fin de cette année nous aurons les
impôts les taxes les cotisations les
plus élevés de toute l'europe
donc il y à de très grands défis à
relever
c'est un projet pour les français il
peut être aussi rédigé par les français
nous allons bien évidemment proposer à
nos adhérents aux sympathisants de
s'exprimer nous avons applications que
je vous recommande de télécharger sur
votre mobile direct citoyens vous serez
régulièrement interrogé questionner
l'idée est de faire remonter des
propositions et que chacun puisse
s'exprimer sur ces questions à condat
mental ici aux républicains dans un
dialogue avec nos adhérents d'abord et
puis avec les français sous l'impulsion
de nicolas sarkozy nous sommes en train
de construire ce projet pour la france
et pour les français un projet
d'ouverture un projet de tolérance un
projet d'intégration un projet d'avenir
tout en faisant en sorte que les
français se reconnaissent dans ce projet
se reconnaissent dans l'avenir de la
france